today on our show or we're gonna get
thrower with it that's right now we're
gonna talk about four :
Ragnarok so much gonna make you Thor
today I'm fat man I'm Batman
on Batman well the fat man out Batman
I'm Kevin Smith and we are doing the
show from our new home here at the scum
and villainy Cantina right here on
historic Hollywood Boulevard right
outside that door Hollywood happen
there's stars on the street there's a
Cahuenga right next door it's all all
them stars they're thinking wait you're
not going what am i doing on the street
no no no I got drunk on Halloween
November 1st boo boo boo boo but this is
what we've been doing the show from now
on as you can see it's it's it's very
reminiscent of some places that you want
to come drink hangout this is where we
do the live show so if you want to get
tickets for the when's the next show
we're doing here we got one on November
14 November 14 and then another one we
just had it on the 20th go to see smart
calm get tickets it's a fun very
laid-back show that's what we used to we
this show has taken many incarnations
and evolved over the years this latest
incarnation is my favorite we get to do
the show with an audience so we're not
just trying to make each other laugh we
get to also try to make people up then
we get into Q&A and so we get to talk
about it's fantastic so come on out see
the show now you hear that that's the
sound of special effects to make this
place look amazing like right here we
got the bubbling colored things but it's
green the blue that's where Hollywood
sounds like this is the sound of
Hollywood so just so we could get clean
sound on this I'm gonna go here and
watch that be there it is so the pretty
colored lights are gone but now you can
hear us a little better and you're gonna
need dearest folks because today we're
talking about the one the only thor
ragnarok directed by take away titi he's
marks my go-to guy I'm gonna get it by
the end of this tape tight take a chai
iike Tiger watch tea tea white tea tea
what a genius this guy is I guess he did
eagle and shark that movie healing shark
he did hunt for the wildered what we do
in the shadows Neely was shadows the
vampire thing he did he work on
Flight of the Conchords I think he just
behind the scenes you some
producer-director cabassa
give a [ __ ] what he's done up until now
dude took a [ __ ] quantum leap with
this movie he took for the least fun
character the Dino Marvel you know
and turned him into the most fun this
movie is pure [ __ ] joy this movie
will turn a frown upside down this movie
is what movies are about the idea we're
gonna take you to some place some
foreign place we're gonna show you
things that couldn't really happen and
stuff you have a good time there was a
plot there was a little bit of motion
but there was a [ __ ] ton a metric [ __ ]
ton of laughs yeah I mean it's as funny
as guardians of the galaxy is very first
movie absolutely is a comedy this is a
different Konica this is a buddy comedy
this is a road picture so I'm almost
like a sitcom it's almost like this is
like what a very expensive Marvel sitcom
but a really great sitcom with like the
laughs per minute ratio is super high
they are not afraid to make fun of
anything they make fun of their own
history there's a moment in the movie
where they're making fun of Avengers 2
age Ultron when when black widows like
sons getting pretty low a real low fat
guy and their time to go to sleep want
to talk to the Hulk down once they
started doing that I'm like oh I love
this
this is [ __ ] fantastic they're making
fun of themselves and their history and
whatnot yeah and like the movie even
opens a little bit with this this fake
play that Loki is putting on an Asgard
with Sam Neill playing Odin yes with
Matt Damon playing low laying low key
again again and with the the the least
note Hemsworth Luke Hemsworth playing
Thor it's kind of amazing it's really
funny you said they're gone like well
it's spoilers bunch of spoilers coming
Odin has been Loki since the end of dark
world yes
Thor dark world or something like that
yeah and so you know they finally
resolved that storyline and so when we
find Odin and he's not Odin these he's
Loki he's putting on a play about like
how Loki saved the earth just rewriting
history putting like a Rocky style
statue of Loki in the middle of town
square vagina
is just a good time and that's even
before you get into the Kate there's so
many people and she ain't Blanche yet of
it all who just choose the scenery has
zero compunction about like complain of
look at this villain look at these
antlers I'm gonna chew the senior and
she Nora Desmond's the Holm oh my god
would you like to share something no now
this is all for me I don't think you'll
ever see an actor actors in this case
having more fun with apart then she did
man I mean I did
maybe she trusts the hell out of that
guy take it but she went for it and it's
it's delightful and they all did that's
the thing it's like there's no weak link
in this movie Tessa Thompson Tessa
Thompson who was a free Hungary and
she's on Westworld the first season
she's amazing the movie the movie does
so many moments which just serves her up
as awesome like here's the entrance
here's the music here's the here's he
badass hero they put her into her outfit
yeah on top of a wing at horse I mean
because come on thank God like when you
saw the trailer for this movie right
away like you like this is different
that the immigrant saw my let's
definitely like this is expensive
they're willing to pay for that song in
the movie they don't even make you wait
for that yeah or they're like you know
you know it's gonna be used in the final
battle right opening it a flick there's
a little bit of chitchat with Thor
finding them in the position he's in and
then just when you know a hammer goes
flying a step BAM in a minute and
minutes the most metal opening to a
movie of all time Marvel movie at least
it is like it is like the the spinal tap
of metal in that the metal is legit
metal like they're not effing around
like the movie is a legit Thor movie but
it's so goddamn funny yes not even and
Chris Hemsworth has no business being as
funny as he is but he isn't like he was
honestly like the funniest thing in the
Ghostbusters movie and and here they
found a way to use him where they didn't
like you know oh let's just make him
goofy because he's been Thor for to Thor
movies and a bunch of Avengers flicks
and whatnot so they don't lessen him by
any stretch of the imagination in fact I
would argue that like one of the most
touching exchanges in any Marvel movie
let alone Thor movies is the one that he
has with Loki in the elevator where he's
finally come to peace with the idea that
like you you and I went our separate
ways a long time ago yeah but like I've
always loved you I've always been on
your side as you were you were my
brother
and for most of our existence you were
my favorite person on the planet it's a
really sweet moment the realm and hit
all the Tom Hiddleston home yeah Tom
Hiddleston you know he has to react to
it and you know acting and it seemed to
actors or extras you know the one who's
doing the meaty here's all the cool
words that make you feel
that's very showy job but then the other
person who has to react and take it in
and you know the history of these
characters I thought he was phenomenal
in his kind of like oh I'm the [ __ ]
but it's it's really quite touching and
then they immediately
I wouldn't say undercut it but like this
is the movie they'll do something like
that something sweet and meaningful and
then like right as its ending yeah
Thor's just like let's do what does it
helps yeah help me help me help no I
don't want to help us he's like come on
it's great he's like it's humiliating
come out of the elevator and he's got
he's holding his brother and look he's
like limping he's like my brother's hurt
help these guards come over he's like
how bad his brother at the guards and
knocks the ball down and like he clearly
enjoys it gone that's great it is it is
they like one step up from the the Star
Wars Chewbacca bit was like put him in
handcuffs tonight I know where he's gone
with his chew it'll be fine don't worry
it's it's pretty it's a pretty magical
film on that level now in terms of the
stakes for the Marvel Universe I think
well something big happened again lots
of spoilers something big happen but
didn't happen on earth and so maybe
that's why it feels like wow this is a
you know a detour from the overarching
Marvel story but I disagree
that well spoilers Asgard Falls in the
movie they don't [ __ ] save it it goes
down
Ragnarok does not get averted they're
not burying the lede they literally told
you in the title what's going to happen
so there is an irrevocable change in the
Marvel Universe just as we've seen an
irrevocable change in the Marvel
Universe and Captain America Civil War
as well they're lining up all their
ducks in a row to prepare for Avengers
where the Avengers store
is like everybody's here and they're all
fractured to like you know Thor's like
I'm more worried about setting up a new
Asgard you know never mind like fan OHS
and stuff you could see the tables being
set for how they're pulling that movie
together and now more than ever I
suspect the first half of Infinity
Gauntlet or infinity wars over the
corner a lot of death like a [ __ ] ton of
major death and I think part two is
gonna be here's your new characters as
we head into Phase what nine of the
Marvel Universe I mean also think that
this is this is a wafer this is a not
wafer because that says it's thin this
is you know when you go to fine
restaurants I've done this once or twice
before they're like you don't have no
pants get out some always wearing jean
shorts before they give you the meal
they give you like a bowl of sherbert
yeah like an aperitif an aperitif if you
will haha
this movie is perhaps the finest
aperitif or whatever to what's coming
right it's it's got some levity but some
steaks it's fun it's very Marvel it's
very self-aware you know it's not like
characters step out and talk to the
camera and break the fourth wall but
it's you know they they play with their
history quite a bunch and I think
between guardians of the galaxy to and
and this this is you know yeah this is
meant to be like enjoy cuz shits about
to get dark right and it's definitely a
tonal bridge between the other Thor
movies and the guardians movies and the
rest of their cosmic universe because
Thor had been a super serious character
for a very long time the first movies
Shakespearean Kenneth Branagh
by design it's a lot of Shakespeare into
that like it was all about like two suns
and trying to please their father and
tragedy and deception and all that stuff
like that movie plus it had the order
the rent destroyer the destroyer yeah
you know the second movie is a bit of a
mess and it is what it is but it's also
remember mazikeen that it al yeah going
for the the air and it turned out to be
one of the infinity and Malik Yuans
Malekith that's there it is you know but
this was a little but the movie solo is
kind of it has the proper moment of that
movie is one point the hammer goes
[ __ ] whiz and by kat dennings and she
goes Miu Miu
oh yeah like that movie suffers from
having too many villains and neither
villain like they couldn't get rid of
Loki because he's the villain of the
Marvel Universe by and large and then
they added Malick effin splitting the
time between them doesn't really play
with that a bunch in this house so -
like a lot of callbacks to the previous
movies when when Loki sees Hulk on what
is that planet called the war world is
scarce a car it's a car when he sees him
there where the contest of Champions is
happening like he fries you know as like
oh my god last time I saw in the studio
and then he does that to Thor and then
later on to when like you know they're
talking about going on earth
Loki's like they're not gonna like me
yeah I've done some [ __ ] oh my god he's
like my [ __ ] outer space Hitler so
that makes me think if you're looking
for a noble death and one that eradicate
Saul the bad he's done mmm telling you
man my song I don't know [ __ ] about [ __ ]
but if I'm you know if I'm looking at
the Marvel Universe based on what
they've given us especially that speech
that he gave to his brother yeah I think
I think the Loki's days may be numbered
you I think I think you're right I think
he's tired of people relying on him to
do the wrong thing and being able to
surprise people by doing the right thing
could actually be interesting let's talk
about Korg pork yeah Rock Monster yeah
take away TT got in the in the mocap
suit and and I heard he was doing that
had no idea how much he was in the major
character and he's quite a bit in there
and it's always so fun of this light
sort of Kiwi accent cutting through this
giant monster yeah especially next to
Thor's all of that kind of cool they
play with God and Lord quite a bit they
do of course you've all seen him in the
trailer Jeff Goldblum holy [ __ ] just
pops in to steal the show just Goldblum
in all over the place and every episode
even one point is like you know on any
other planet I'd be millions of years
but on his car and a whole audience went
nuts man and I'm like wow this is people
honoring a dude's life a lifetime of
work and and very curious delivery yeah
like there's there's no moment in this
movie where he is not Jeff Goldblum and
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter he's
not giving up performance as much as
he's showing up to just grace us with
his presence and I'm cool with that and
that's what the whole movie feels like
as a bunch of people came to play in a
fun way even you know what's his name
Anthony Hopkins previous two outings you
know he's old and he doesn't have a
bunch of yucky up lines or anything like
that but he's very stern their name is
grim no for nothing NASA's true and at
least in the opening of this while he
was you know pretending to be Tom
Hiddleston's version of Loki like he
looked like he was having a [ __ ]
blast like you know you watch Westworld
and Andy Hopkins always so saddened
hours that character is it violent
delights have violent ends seemed like
everybody had a good time make a movie
this guy like he's a he's like a James
Gunn this Taika Waititi he just blends
well with that material insanely well
give him more and not just the work give
him like give him other things and feels
like he loves working with actors and
feels like he loves what do you want to
what's the best version of you let's get
that yeah whatever it takes you know and
it's it's a vast leap from the other
kind of work that you've been doing you
know like every other move you made ten
million fifty million dollars a New
Zealand was just like the like this
movie is a hundred times two hundred
times the most expensive movie ever made
or something like that but the end of
the day yeah you make a movie like that
and you've got like a team of effects
Wizards who are gonna make Asgard and
make Korg come to life and all that
stuff but at the end of the day at the
heart of all of this [ __ ] is a human
element yeah and he brought humanity to
that movie the fun of humanity the
silliness of Manatee while they're
telling a story about gods from another
planet and stuff so it's it's not just
like you owe it to yourself to go see
the movie because it's pure fun yeah if
you don't giggle once you're in the
movie I don't know what to tell you but
there's serious giggle moments all
throughout but more importantly like
this is the common
book moviemaking that should be
supported like stuff where I mean look
it should all be supported but this is
what I'm into stuff that when I sit
there it makes me feel like I felt when
I was a kid reading comic books maybe I
didn't laugh as much as when I was a kid
you know as I did during this movie
that's okay I'm an adult I need a little
something now too you know to lean the
Wonder on because you know 46 47 47 now
the wonder of like people in costumes
flying and doing good holy [ __ ] Batman
I've had years and years of that but the
wonder of life hey Thor just said
something really funny based on his
entire history and yet it's still heroic
that's a new element and I think they're
killing it in the Marvel movies with it
they've always been able to sprinkle in
pure joy these flicks feel like I felt
when I was reading this stuff when I was
a kid when I was watching the cartoons
when I was dreaming they would do movies
like this and then you write those
dreams off gone no one would ever make a
Thor movie like and they did they made
three and this one is hands-down the
best and that doesn't really pay it the
full complement it's do it is by and
large the best of the three the Thor
movies and probably form a top-ten
Marvel Universe instantly right off the
bat yeah I mean it's not it's not a deep
movie you know like I've talked about
that we walked out it's it's especially
the middle of it has a little bit of
like this gossamer feel where it's like
delightful and wonderful and it just
kind of evaporates in your hands I think
that's the lack of stakes because
Earth's not really involved I think that
was the arrogance of two earth men going
like well it's kind of light in the
middle because there was no real threat
yeah it's it's about the sort of
reconciliation of brothers in a way like
all these movies have been about
Brotherhood and and in that way it kind
of works but there is no Big Bad coming
to destroy the earth there is no massive
mall the universe you know continuity
that they're hammering on that will lead
us somewhere else unintended pun
intended but it's still like it just it
carries you through with this blight
grace that's kind of just wonderful to
watch it's not it's not deep but what
you get is wonderful trying to think
what I can compared to the warm feeling
certainly not the tone or the content or
whatever but like big Tom Hanks movie
big whenever I watch big it
I love it it's warm they got some really
legit funny [ __ ] in it and there's a lot
of heart in that movie
there's heart in this movie maybe not as
much emotion but crazy a crazy amount of
emotion considering what that movie is
tell me that scene in the elevator alone
is pretty moving stuff spoilers
Odin passing is even though you know
it's shot on green-screen and stuff like
that clip it is moving you know as two
brothers lose their father and heat
addresses both of them and so is there's
some there's some really moving stuff in
it but it's just joy dude from start to
finish it reminded me of Midnight Run oh
what a great poem thank you what a great
poem but it's which is a riff you've
never seen Midnight Run [ __ ] go see
midnight Ron it's it's it's Robert De
Niro and Charles Grodin he De Niro is a
bounty hunters getting to pull in his
the blue collared criminal white-collar
criminal you believe we're in a world
where somebody has to actually explain
the plot of midnight run but you're
absolutely but I feel like you're right
some people out there like me didn't run
what's that yeah so like the mob wants
to get this guy to prevent him from
testifying against him and so he's Jack
De Niro has to deliver this guy but it's
just it's a super fun romp that does get
serious does take a little dip where you
understand why De Niro's character is as
removed from humanity as it is because
he's removed from his family like he's
estranged from his wife he hasn't seen
his daughter in years and years and
years and you get why such a [ __ ]
grump there's a there's an element of
that here then of guys who have tragedy
that's infected their lives but they
they're unwilling to face it to stare
down and so it's fun like we're just
we're escaping from our drama they're
having a good time
he's absolutely right here's something
we also haven't really talked about Hulk
holy [ __ ] this is a this is one of those
movies where you're like I'm glad they
never gave Hulk his own movie they can't
because the universal thing right they
did one
Marvel ain't gonna do it again because
Universal owns the Hulk and that movie
would have to be through them so they're
just gonna use Hulk like crazy in all
their movies and if that's the plan
they used him expertly in this movie not
only is like well it wasn't a surprise
because we saw him
trailer right but which I do sort of
wish that I had but still come on I mean
I get it how do you not sell there like
I know but like you could have you still
could've sold a Thor movie and [ __ ]
Valkyrie and awesome [ __ ] my bets man
put a little green in there maybe the
green comes out I know
but imagine how amazing that moment
would have been like now that I got my
money
that's what I want more than anything
else is you to be in the theater for the
experience so I his what's his name Mark
Ruffalo wonderful but the Hulk the Hulk
himself they evolved a little bit in
this movie where he's kind of like the
Peter David not full-on smart Hulk yet
but like he can have discussions not
just like Hulk smash like you know they
started with with that uni or puny God
and stuff like that now you can sit
there and have a conversation Hulk like
father
Thor is also like fun yeah but
originally for most moldering fire the
champion wearing the towel the towel
drop in and Thor being like whoa Canon's
NEC Hulk ass at one point it was is they
used the character insanely yeah well
and then remember at one point like you
know who was a Mark Ruffalo he's like
Tessa Thompson scared Valkyrie and and
Hulk Valkyrie knows Hulk is Hulk and
then all a sudden banners there and
she's like do I know you
yeah well yeah it's a finally like in a
heroic moment you know he's like you do
know me and they jumps out of a plane
and you know in Hulk lore he can change
it will like in the Avengers he was like
that's my secret captain I'm always
angry and he turns into Hulk as well he
[ __ ] lands on the rainbow there's so
much fun totally what was that
remember you know Marvel had the comic
what if but then they also have the
comic what the or something like that
where they did like funny stuff feels a
little bit like that feels like we
wouldn't join someone else there's a lot
of pratfalls it's a fun movie this is I
know the box office has been slumped for
the last two weeks or whatever
Halloween's always a terrible time at
the box
take it from the guy that really zack
and miri on halloween but the this is
the movie the box office has been
waiting for breathlessly everybody's
gonna come out and see this and then in
two weeks everybody gets to go out and
see Justice League right after that it's
already made something like a hundred
and five million overseas I know here we
are Americans going oh it's coming it'll
do well they're already opened up over
seasons [ __ ] kill and doom killer
business this movie is what movies are
made for and honestly like I say this
after I see a lot of things but I
honestly mean it like and when I say it
and I really mean it when I say it about
this you watch a movie like that I'm
like oh [ __ ] I used to call myself a
director that's so silly like that guy
is a director like did a phenomenal
[ __ ] job need a lot of money and a
lot of toys and stuff put them all the
good use not a single [ __ ] moment
really wasted yeah not at all good [ __ ]
man Wow none of its it's there nothing
it's a sores off man it puts wings on
the side of your head just like Thor's
helmet stretch I know flies like that on
a [ __ ] poster yeah and was a little
like a tip of the hat from Moliere who
spoilers or of wha Steven the trailer is
gone yeah bad that is not a trick and
[ __ ] like yo mom y'all near but then
there's a real Wizard of Oz moment of
like you know the power was always
inside of your the god of thunder not
the god of hammers it's goddamn in this
movie's good you make me want to go see
you know I'm gonna go this weekend again
I can take my kid I'm gonna take my kids
hey kids there it is man you just seen
this Baha I slobber all over thor
ragnarok let us know you thought of it
in the comment section below I learned
how to do that nice job or did that
before well played but that's all we got
time for this week that was a lot of
time I think the review is as long as
the movie itself for Batman I'm Batman
I'm Kevin Smith I'm mark Renard
tune in next week same fad time same fad
channels Marquez calm or youtube.com
slash Kevin Smith
[Music]
[Applause]
you